herr breaking news seine messerattacke
in hamburg eine 20 jahre alte frau
wartet nichts ahnend auf den bus als ein
maskierter mann plötzlich hinter ihr
auftaucht und unvermittelt mehrmals mit
einem messer auf sie ein sticht passiert
ist das heute morgen am bahnhof
mümmelmannsberg in hamburg eine
großfahndung nach dem täter läuft wir
bleiben natürlich dran melden uns sofort
wenn es dort mehr information mehr unser
reporter ist sogar jetzt schon kurz für
uns vor ort jan-hendrik dobers bild
reporter dort weißt du schon irgendetwas
über den täter mensch immer wieder diese
messer taten jan-hendrik
[Musik]
und er hört uns nicht gesehen er unser
bild reporter auf der suche nach unserem
ton den haben wir gleich gefunden ja ich
kann jetzt verlieren sie schnell auf die
straße dort zu dem tatort also was weißt
du über den täter war unsere frage
ja wir haben einen bislang unbekannten
täter laut polizei die
fahndungsmaßnahmen ihr im stadtteil
nürnberg/hamburg sie laufen immer noch
dass ich auch weiter ausgedehnt auf das
gebiet das ist nur bekannt dass er wohl
die junge frau gekannt haben muss und
diese tat auch gezielt abgelaufen ist
nur wo sich dieser mann im moment
aufhält dazu gibt es noch keine
informationen
ein gezielter angriff sagst du das
gehört zu dieser taten gezielter angriff
kein zufälliger angriff auf diese frau
ja ich habe mit menschen hier vor ort
brauchen wir auch heute morgen hier an
der bushaltestelle standen und die haben
gesagt dass dieser mann aufgespannt
jährige frau gut gegangen mit
einem auf ihrer sicht spitzen gegenstand
was nicht als besser herausgestellt hat
und dann mindestens ein stich aus diese
auf diese frau ausführte warum und in
welcher beziehung diese beim ist und
noch nicht bekommen was weißt du über
den gesundheitszustand der frau wie geht
es ihr
die frau ist mit schwersten verletzungen
laut polizeiangaben in eine klinik
gebracht worden
ja also in dem moment dann nicht mehr
ansprechbar gewesen aber zumindest war
nach unserer kenntnis bislang eine lese
gern trinkt oberst uns zugeschaltet aus
hamburg vielen herzlichen dank für diese
informationen über die messerattacke
dort an einer bushaltestelle am frühen
morgen danke